a political strategist on msnbc by the
way just for those of you who
are not in the cable news business who
are not in the political media
when you see someone come on television
it says political strategist
that is a synonym for unemployed
if they have a job it will say what
their job is if they don't it's a
political
strategist have you uh that's not that's
not a real job so this this woman
susan del percho goes on to
msnbc and
building upon this idea that democrats
are dehumanizing republicans she said
it's very clear
right now the gop needs to burn
to the ground i've been looking for a
new word for trumpism because i hate it
because i think it goes deeper than just
donald trump within the republican party
and i keep coming back to the same name
it's
neo-fascism it needs to burn down
it literally needs to be demolished
before you can go in and build it up
again and you know the people who
actually say
why you know please stay republican are
democrats
who like to say let's argue back tax
policy because they know you need a
strong
republican party right now it's not
strong but it needs
it really does need to to be burned down
to the ground
so it can come back up but that also
means there has to be people willing
to keep their republican credentials to
be there when it's time to build it up
george orwell is often invoked in these
sorts of political discussions
and rightly so because he made some good
observations not just in 1984 but in an
essay called politics and english
language
in that essay orwell says that fascism
and he wrote this many many years ago
fascism no longer has any meaning
fascism now means no more than
something that i do not like something
that i do not desire
right this woman i suspect could not
define fascism
you know they tell us that we can't
define critical race theory yes we can
critical race theory is an academic
movement that developed over the past
30 or 40 years that says that america's
defining feature is its anti-black
bigotry
and that this permeates every aspect of
the united states
including its its uh system of property
including its
its its economics and it derives from a
broader marxist tradition that's true
and you can read about it in my book
speechless and you can read about it in
other sources as well
what is fascism according to this woman
it's nothing george orwell writes in
this essay
that when when people don't want to
think not even when they can't think but
when they don't want to think
they just you just open your mind up to
cliches
and then the cliches fill your head and
then they will do the thinking for you
and that's that's what has happened this
woman says
it's a neo-fascist party doesn't define
what that is
then she says you know
it needs to be burned to the ground and
we need a strong gop why why does this
woman i don't want a strong democratic
party why does this one want a strong
republican party
it's just a thing that she said it
doesn't mean anything and then she says
we
because right now it's not strong well
if it's not strong what are you so
worried about why does it need to be
burned to the ground
you're worried because it is strong this
is like when people including nancy
pelosi
complained to donald trump that the
border wall
was ineffective and inhumane
hold on which is it if it's ineffective
then it's not inhumane because it's not
bothering anybody
if it's inhumane then it's not
ineffective because it's actually doing
something
but it's just these words that don't
mean anything they just fill the air
it's so
beyond any political point that this
woman thinks that she's making
it's this shallowness this pathetic
rhetoric that just does it's just
words it's it's not even words it's just
grunting it's like it's
somehow below the level of speech and
obviously very
dehumanizing you'll notice not that
republicans can't get riled up but when
we speak about people on the left
we tend to be a little calmer because we
know where they're coming from we know
what their premises are we know how
they're going to get to a conclusion
it's too bad it's bad for the country we
want to stop it but we get it
with these people i mean goodness
gracious this
woman is about as shrill as it gets
because they don't understand they
actually don't understand where we're
coming from they don't get
why someone would vote for donald trump
or whoever the next nominee is going to
be or
or before trump it was romney was the
worst guy ever remember that
then it was mccain then it was bush and
then
is our democracy you see our democracy
demands that we have a strong republican
party but not
a but and now it's weak but it's also
too strong and it doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense stop heed my
warning before the kovid cops come
knocking at your door you got to watch
this whole episode that's the title of
it when the kobe cups come knocking
you can get it here on youtube subscribe
like you can get it
at apple podcast google play stitcher
over at the michael knowles show podcast
leave me a comment let me know what you
think and especially let me know what
you think of my new book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now
wherever books are sold unless it's a
lib bookstore in which case you'll have
to special order it see you next time
you